Alex Earl is 2023's social media it girl
I mean it's basically whole Tick Tock
genre now to make commentary videos on
this girl and like break down the
marketing genius behind every one of her
posts but for a little background Alex
is a Jersey Shore marketing student who
went viral for her get ready with me
videos on Tick Tock and soon became one
of tick tock's fastest growing creators
of all times she has become the queen of
relatability not a lot of successful
influencers showcase them going to the
Magic Mike Premiere and meeting Channing
Tatum and then just going to class the
next day so today we're going to be
taking a stab at eating like the world's
current Tick Tock Obsession Alex Earl
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
in today's video I will be attempting to
eat in the style of viral influencer
Alex Earl but of course not without
adding some OG Abby sharp Flair and
throwing in some Hunger crushing combos
a quick disclaimer that this die is
compiled from random wedding a day
videos that Alex has posted online so I
really cannot speak to the full spectrum
of Alex's diet ultimately it doesn't
matter because the alleged meals that
you'll see here in her videos are just
going to be used as a template for
teaching judge nutrition and for my own
meal inspo this is what I ate on a
random day and is not meant to be copied
or recommended as how you should eat so
always speak to registered dietitian
about your unique needs and if you are a
newcomer to my channel hello there don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
follow me on Tick Tock and Instagram at
Abby's kitchen I feel like Alex's
superpower is that she's got a
reputation for being undeniably
relatable despite obviously having a lot
of privilege so she's talked about her
struggle with acne her academic career
her not so neat and tidy set that's
right my girl's messy and I also can
relate so basically before re-filming I
just scoop up all the mess and throw it
over there
I'll deal with it later
she literally embodies like the cool
girl Trope she somehow perfected the art
of coming across as kind of like a hot
mess but at the same time is so
impossibly beautiful and well put
together I'm telling you there is going
to be full marketing courses in
University offered just to go over Alex
Earl but anyways I'm hungry and I need
my coffee fix Alex help a girl out
[Music]
[Applause]
okay when I say I Vibe I mean I Vibe
with how Alex like Sarah needs her black
crow iced coffee and they do say if you
speak kindly to plants beautiful things
will grow and coffee is like technically
a plant so maybe she's onto something
I'm usually a hot coffee kind of girl
but I feel like our gen Zed girlies love
their iced coffee situation so I'm gonna
entertain it
okay no I am actually obsessed but your
girl needs only to eat so let's take a
look what Alex has for breakfast I
always start off with some type of eggs
scramble mix I'll do spinach tomatoes
and mushrooms top it off with hot sauce
it's filling and healthy love this for
us and like eggs are a great base but
your girl cannot just live on eggs alone
usually I like a little carb action to
accompany my eggs and I also cannot eat
eggs without a ton of cheese so let's
throw some sourdough in the old toaster
and Abby can you talk about some of the
most optimal foods for breakfast
obviously a balance of protein carbs and
fat is ideal for any meal but if I had
to prioritize at breakfast I would
really be focusing in on that balance of
protein which Alex has in the eggs plus
some carbs we know that a high protein
breakfast can help to raise daily
appetite hormones throughout the rest of
the day and we also know that because
we're more insulin sensitive in the
morning focusing the bulk of our
carbohydrates earlier on in the day has
some great known metabolic benefits so
this is a reminder to not fear the
breakfast carbs a little bit of tomatoes
get these eggs down
do you guys put water or milk in your
scrambled eggs I just
go all natural where's my butter butter
I am just not prepared one second Touch
of olive oil a little bit of butter
because I like
flavor of butter with my eggs let's see
what you got here some general Greenery
I can stick in here leftover snap peas
that have been cooked
a little bit of broccoli probably good
and some potatoes maybe like a hash
situation
this is why I love scramble mornings
because you like literally can just use
whatever random bits and pieces of food
you have in the house and make a whole
new dish every single time
oh she's
spicy yeah
salted up
now let's put in
accompaniments what accoutrements was
the word I was trying to say
oh man Abby
it's not even Monday I'm gonna do a
combo here of mozzarella cheese and this
like cheddar cheese
because why not
nice also going to bump up the protein
oh here's our egg I don't know how to
make an omelet so this I feel like I
could make an omelette with let's try
oh
this is risky guys
this is why I just do scrambles like
a scramble is just a broken omelette
it's an omelette with more personality
let's stop that cheese melt that's
hearty like that's gonna be super
satisfying I love that all right we got
our toast what we gonna do with that
baby all right
we got our sourdough down I got a little
avocado and she is like perfectly ripe
if you got a ripe avocado you cannot
just not use it like I don't even care
if you dislike avocados it is your duty
to use the avocado when it says it's
time to be used all right so she's going
down other half down use that I'll use
that at lunch
noise a little salt and pepper
a couple tomatoes
let's do a little balsamic glaze
it's my favorite avocado toast Edition
Eggies look at this
this looks banging
nice oh
this is a little too excited there I
don't even need any fruit this is just
giving me life all right let's talk
about it Alex uses like a classic hot
sauce and that's great that's cool we
love that too but I have this Curry
ketchup and oh my God it just hits
different it's spicy it's aromatic it's
a little bit sweet from like the ketchup
situation so that's my current New Egg
up session I'm gonna throw that on top
we have lots of protein in our eggs and
some in the cheese as well we've got
fiber rich carbs in our potatoes and our
sourdough toast healthy fats in the
olive oil and in the avocado and lots of
micronutrients and fiber with all those
veg I snuck in there let me try to get
like a oh a really cheesy look at that
you get that you get that you get that
whoa oh we're still going we are still
going
wow
how do I eat this
[Music]
Alex darling you got out of the trees
okay so this is the time of day when our
girl Alex usually goes for a scoop of
her favorite greens powders as a way to
allegedly prevent bloating like she
doesn't even skip it on her wedding day
I can't be bloated on my wedding day so
here we go
foreign
so I've watched a lot of Alex's videos
of course and I've noticed that she uses
this one by bloom a lot so I'm assuming
she's like an ambassador for them but I
get a ton of questions about greens
powders specifically this one by Bloom
so Abby I think you could break this one
down for us you got it so I've discussed
greens powders Ad nauseam on my channel
right here so check that out if you want
a thorough breakdown but in short I
really see greens powders as like a
powdered multivitamin not a replacement
for a whole veg which ultimately will
pack a lot more natural fiber if we look
specifically at this influencer backed
blend from Bloom we can see that most of
their marketing and influencer marketing
is based around it being like a powerful
anti-bloating solution but I would argue
that for a lot of folks it's actually
potentially going to cause bloating if
we look at the ingredients there are
some digestive enzymes and probiotics
which may help to improve suggestion but
the added fiber sources here are very
likely to kind of cancel all that out
the fiber sources are coming from major
FODMAP bombs including chicory root
fructoligosaccharides and inulin anyone
suffering from legitimate bloating is
likely going to feel horrible after a
shot of this but the biggest issue that
I take with this product is that it
lacks third-party testing and as I've
established in my video right here the
supplement world is the wild west so if
you take anything away from this is to
choose a supplement that has been third
party tested I think there's a time and
place for things like greens powders you
know specifically if you're not getting
any produce in your day but before I
commit myself to a very expensive
supplement let's see what Alex is having
for lunch
for a lunch snack I did this Chia
parfait it's from puravita it's my
absolute favorite or I guess we should
say like snack number one Alex seems to
be much more of like a grazer girly
um rather than kind of like having
specific sit-down full meals which is
great for a lot of people but not so
great for me Abby can you give us a
little explainer why you got it it comes
down to our little friend the migratory
Motor complex so very quickly the
migratory Motor complex is like a big
sweeping broom that moves food along the
digestive tract every 90 to 130 minutes
or so every time we put anything with
calories into our mouth it halts the MMC
and it forces it to start the process
all over again and if we're not allowing
this MMC to occur in full bacteria can
more easily pool and flourish so for
folks like myself with a history of
functional gut disorders it's often
important to try our best to give our
body full full and thorough MMC waves so
yeah yeah I think I'm gonna eat
these like mini meals as one bigger meal
that will hopefully Carry Me on until
dinner so in one of Alex's wedding a day
videos she has her greens powder and
then she has some chips and salsa on
their own for lunch and then in another
one she has this like chia pudding
parfait and a little kind of like immune
booster shot and then has chips with
salsa after that I don't mind this
because I love me a good chip dip
situation and if there's enough sugar in
the chia pudding I'm on board with that
too and in classic Alex Earl style I'm
gonna overpay for Mine by ordering it
from a super bougie juice bar and
basically spending way more than had I
just made it myself but of course I'm
going to supplement with the chips that
I got at like the Dollarama because as
Alex says balance is key do not restrict
yourself okay so I got my overpriced
immunity shot and chia pudding I got my
chips and I got my salsa I still am
feeling like this is leaving selling to
be desired I know I'm like 10 years
older than Alex but I just know for me
that I need a little more fiber and a
little more protein in my lunch to feel
my best so I think I'm going to turn
this into like a taco salad situation
and then kind of like have the chia
pudding for dessert we'll see how it
goes and since we are making a salad I
would say that powdered greens is
totally obsolete so I've just saved
myself about 50 bucks with that while I
get chopping Abby can you tell me a
little bit more about these immunity
shots yeah so this seems to be made with
orange and pineapple juice ginger garlic
honey cayenne and oregano all nutritious
ingredients we're getting lots of
antioxidants plus some other
antibacterial antimicrobial and
anti-fungal properties but a you cannot
boost your immune system with juice or
anything else hard stop and B even if
you could the chances of you getting a
functional dose in a shot that is 99
overpriced orange juice is nil so again
you're better off just taking a
multivitamin and eating a balanced diet
step one
we got the lettuce
and you can't use any fancy ass lettuce
for this like you know no arugula no
spinach no kale you need something with
solid crunch I was going to go for
Iceberg which is my personal fave but I
thought we would upgrade a slight notch
on the nutritional belt and go with
Romaine so that's going down black beans
nice
we got some frozen corn that I just
thought out love a good sweet corn
bite that just went flying do you guys
see that
um bell pepper
nice
some tomatoes
a little cheese
Tex-Mex
big dollop of
our pico de gallo
right here and some guac
right here
for dressing we're going to keep things
simple we got lime
ah
a little avocado oil since we're doing
the avocado theme Here
some what
Over the Rainbow
salt and pepper
and my secret ingredient hot honey if
you know you know and hot honey makes a
surprisingly delicious like Tex-Mex
Mexican style dressing
oh
that'll do give her a whisk
oh my gosh most important part the chips
think of the chips as like your crouton
they're going to add a lot of crunch and
a lot of salt we love that great glad I
spent eight dollars on two ounces of
orange juice but anyways I am
legitimately glad I took the time to put
this bad boy together and I kind of like
cleared out the fridge with any bits and
pieces that I had let's talk about it so
we've got tons of fiber going on in all
of our veg plus our fruit and our Chia
we've got healthy fats in the dressing
the guacamole on top and the Chia as
well protein in the beans and the chia
pudding and we got a little carb action
as well with all of our chips so many
antioxidants here so much great
nutrition no powdered greens or immunity
shot can beat that
mmm
why
I need to cleanse my palate with this
cream
surprisingly good probably a lot of
sugar in this that's the only way to
make chia pudding tastes good
um
coconut cream
all right before Alex's workout she opts
for a pre-workout supplement and based
on her video it seems like she's using
the amino lean supplement that I've seen
a lot of influencers on Tick Tock use
Abby what's the deal on pre-workouts are
they necessary and are they even safe so
pre-workouts are safe for most healthy
individuals but they're definitely not
necessary to reach your Fitness goal
this one by Amino lean has 130
milligrams of caffeine so about two
shots of espresso worth which is
generally the most functional
evidence-based ingredient in pre-workout
Blends there's also an amino acid blend
that contains L-Arginine and
l-citrulline both of which have some
evidence for exercise performance but
the clinical dose is around three to six
grams and 8 000 milligrams respectively
and because there's only five grams
total in this proprietary blend it's
highly unlikely we're gonna get a
functional dose this particular
supplement also touts a weight
management blend filled with a
proprietary blend of CLA green coffee
extract and green tea extract and while
research suggests that these ingredients
may have very small impacts on weight
again judging by by the proprietary
blend it's highly unlikely we're going
to be getting any kind of clinical dose
so yeah you could probably skip that
noted I have like a strict 10 30 a.m cut
off for caffeine hashtag insomnia so I'm
gonna pass on the Pre-Workout the
combination of this morning's coffee and
the OG energy AKA food is good enough
for me to fuel this workout so let's get
on the treadmill and get two birds
stoned at once two birds stone at once
Alex Style by creating a little Tick
Tock content at the same time get your
ass up and work
foreign
we got some work done I snuck in a
little bit of movement I banged some
tick tocks for the next few days love it
I feel very productive today so
according to Alex's tick tock on one day
she makes a really quickie warm salad
with some shrimp and has some soup
dumplings on the side and then on
another day she's got this chicken and
rice bowl with sweet potato broccoli and
a side of mac and cheese both sound
amazing though I am thinking I'm gonna
go with option number two because I also
have leftover mac and cheese in my
fridge I make mac and cheese at least
once a week because it is one of my
son's favorite foods and mine as well so
I'm definitely excited to put a little
of that on my plate so I'm gonna go pull
up some ingredients to make a little
chicken rice sweet potato nourish Bowl
but give it my own little Abby twist
let's do it
okay we got some broccoli
I've got some sweet potatoes
and these are frozen so they will cook
and roast up just as fast as the
broccoli
a little olive oil
salt and pepper
I'm gonna pop these into a 450 degree
oven until they're cooked and roasted
and delicious really quick little sauce
here for our nourish Bowl I got some
tahini
some lemon juice
a little maple syrup
and a touch of olive oil or avocado oil
whatever you like
if it's a little too thick you just add
a couple of little tablespoons of water
and it'll thin out nicely
we got some leftover rice from the night
before
got our broccoli what's the easiest way
to do this without burning myself
[Music]
okay there we go sweet potatoes
we've got some rotisserie chicken I'm
all about the shortcuts friends I've
also got some apple I just like a little
fresh crunch in my nourish Bowl so she's
going down I think we're gonna do some
pistachios
because any little crunch Factor
nice I think a little zatar would be
banging on this and our little simple
Maple tahini dressing
and I pulled out some mac and cheese
leftovers so I don't even know where to
start but I'm very excited about this so
let's do a little recap we've got our
five Rich carbs and our Apple sweet
potato our whole grain rice I've also
got some more carbs in the mac and
cheese situation lots of fiber in our
veg and our fruit we've got some protein
in our chicken healthy fats in the
tahini and the nuts and some mac and
cheese for good measure I'm starting
here folks
look at that
um
I'm so glad
hmm
so you guys know I need a little
something something before bed I'm a big
bedtime snack girly and our girl Alex
really displays like quite a range here
so in one video she has tea straight up
that's it and then in another one she
has like a series of really delicious
crunchy crispy snacks and I'm partial to
those sour cream and onion chips like I
love me some sour cream and onion chips
so I'm gonna pair those sour cream and
onion chips with tea and I'm also going
to make like a really easy Greek yogurt
dip to go with it just with whatever
spices I have in the house not a lot of
nutrition but that's totally okay I
appreciate that Alex is simply reacting
and responding to her hunger cues and
maybe the nourish bowl with the mac and
cheese side really hit the spot but the
shrimp salad kind of left something to
be desired so she needed to kind of play
catch up on the Carby snacks before bed
let me go get that snack and we'll keep
chatting okay super easy hack here got
some nice full fat Greek yogurt and just
store-bought ranch dip
seasoning you can also get the French
onion one but I feel like with the sour
cream and onion chips Ranch just hit
stove room you can add as much or as
little seasoning as you'd like
also Alex I noticed that you used
Straight lays sour cream and onion chips
what are you doing everyone knows a sour
cream and onion needs to be in ruffle
form please argue with me in the
comments below if you disagree
because I am ready to fight to the death
on this one you agree right I don't
think I have Ruffles in the states
yeah but they have roughly yeah they
have ruffly chips
and even if you guys don't have Ruffles
down in the States you have roughly
chips I know that there are roughly
chips out there I've ordered roughly
chips the thick chips The Ridges The
Ridges you know what I'm talking about
these hold more flavor more crunch
I mean I I could just go on for hours
about this let's have some taste
onion is not going to feel great for my
IBS but let me tell you she's worth it
so Alex actually closes both of these
wedding a day videos by saying that you
know balance is key guys never restrict
yourself and I would say that even
though there probably wasn't enough
physical food in this day for my needs
it certainly did not feel restrictive
normal eating can be unpredictable it
can mean having multiple little grazing
meals for the day rather than designated
meals it can mean taking supplements
that make you feel good to take the
pressure off of always having to eat
right and it can mean making yourself a
low carb meal only to realize that it
kind of left you feeling unsatisfied or
unsatiated so you need multiple carb
heavy snacks to fill the void and most
importantly it's making these choices
100 judgment free so I appreciate Alex
showing us what normal eating can look
like on social media it's not perfect
it's not always well planned and it's
not necessarily always pretty but if it
works for her you know it works for me
now I realize I took some creative
Liberties in this day but but that's
probably the difference between being a
22 year old and being a 35 year old I
probably at exactly
exactly when I was 22 and I probably
felt great chips would have 100 been a
meal and I would have never thought
anything about it being good or bad nor
do I think that now but I now have
almost a decade on this girl just
collecting data on how foods make me
feel like how do these Foods affect my
digestion my mood my energy level my
sleep so they could just goes to show
what variation there is when it comes to
what intuitive eating can look like
intention is key while shame guilt and
judgment absolutely is not and on that
note guys that's all that I have for you
guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with whose diet you'd like
to see me try out next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
okay
[Music]